I would like us to think bigger.
It is time to start a conversation
about using the windfall
profits of frozen Russian assets
to jointly purchase military equipment for Ukraine.
There could be no stronger symbol
and no greater use for that money
than to make Ukraine
and all of Europe a safer place to live.
On other members.
Ultimately, this is about Europe taking responsibility
for its own security.
The simple truth is
we do not have the luxury of comfort.
We do not have the control of elections
or decisions in other parts of the world.
We simply do not have the time
to skirt around the issue.
Whistle. Without the support of our partners,
we cannot let Russia win.
And the cost of insecurity,
the cost of a Russian victory,
is far greater than any saving we could make now.
And this is why it is time for Europe to step up.
Long live Europe!